[Musique]
il ya le plaisir bonjour bonjour
messieurs parti et bonjour à la
martinique et alain joseph en
particulier à la tête de la liste
ensemble réussi au saint joseph soutenu
par le mouvement bas payant chose que
vous présidez d'ailleurs vous parvenez
en tête du premier tour de scrutin à
saint-joseph donc le 15 mars avec 1848 à
ses 43 % des voix vous avez devos evo9
adversaires quelle est votre lecture des
résultats de ce premier tour de scrutin
d'abord je remercie les électeurs qui
m'ont fait confiance qui sont très
nombreux je pense qu'ils m'ont adopté et
que s'il n'y avait pas eu autant de
candidats j'aurais sans doute été élu au
premier tour
vous l'avez rappelé le score de notre
liste est de 43% et la liste qui suit
fait 11% des voix
bon donc je dirais que c'est quand même
une indication assez significatif de la
volonté des jeux et enfin je rappelle
qu'il ya une triangulaire à saint-joseph
puisque le deuxième candidat camille mal
est fait environ 11% des voix et le 3e
laura cette norme est un peu près les
mêmes scores restent bon sens également
les deux se sont maintenus une recette
et angulaire est ce que l'abstention
très forte du premier tome nous a
désavantagés ou au contraire vous pensez
que ça reflète l'état de l'électorat
dans la cour je pense que l'abstention a
peut-être peut-être pas permis que je
passe au premier tour parce que
peut-être que ça aurait pu être possible
avec une plus forte participation
mais je sais aussi touché chacun des
candidats des autres candidats donc
l'abstention malheureusement c'est tout
à fait regrettable parce que c'est un
enjeu important braud saint joseph et
j'appelle donc à la mobilisation pour le
deuxième tour et j'espère que là là là
peut-être parce que les choix seront
plus simples pour les électeurs neuf
listes c'est toujours cette dispersion
des voix donne d'abord le sentiment
électeurs qu'il y aura deux tours dans
leur esprit et ensuite que ma foi ils
ont pour une raison ou pour une autre
un choix plus compliqué alors si vous
être élu maire de saint joseph bientôt
le 28 juin prochain quel projet saute
aux yeux vous mettre en oeuvre quand
priorité alors ce que je souhaite mettre
d'abord sermet une organisation au sein
de la collectivité
les services de la collectivité sont à
peu près d organiser je souhaite donc
rencontré chacun
des membres de la du personnel de cette
collectivité échanger avec eux remettre
un peu d'organisation comme je le dis
parce que si on n'a pas l'administration
pourra pas faire qu'est ce qu'on va
faire et qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
on veut d'abord revitaliser le centre
ville je les ai expliqué et dans les
quartiers répond dans la tente des gens
que les gens puissent avoir de l'eau de
l'électricité que les routes soient
entretenus que l'élagage soit fait qu'il
y ait des espaces pour pour les échanges
et puis nous souhaitons aussi à que
notre politique sociale soit plus
dynamique plus plus plus efficace en
direction des personnes démunies en
direction des jeunes avec ceux qui sont
en errance mais sait aussi que qui ont
besoin qu'on les soutienne en
particulier après toutes ces crises sur
le plan de l'éducation
donc nous avons une vision assez assez
exhaustive des problèmes qui nous
attendent mais mais nous avons aussi un
plan pour cela la crise sanitaire qui
n'est pas totalement terminée même si
l'épidémie et disons sous contrôle
comment organisez vous vous même et
votre équipe cette campagne sachant
qu'il y a des interdictions pas de
rassemblement public pas de porte à
porte dans des réunions de maisons
d'appartements
c'est un peu plus compliqué pour les
candidats d'aller à la rencontre des
électrices et des électeurs
oui c'est tout à fait vrai d'autant que
nous avions institue un système de
rencontres chez l'habitant
nous avions donc des réunions dans les
différents quartiers chez un habitant ou
on réunissait trente quarante cinquante
personnes selon les circonstances et
nous ne pourrons pas le faire cette
fois-ci donc comme on peut en nous eh
bien d'abord à en privant prévenant
évidemment toutes les tous les risques
nous avons ouvert notre permanence nous
allons de vendée de la population en
parts des distributions de tracts
nous nous nous évitons de rencontrer
trop de monde à la fois mais nous
prenons les précautions nécessaires mais
nous rencontrons aussi les personnes
nous leur téléphonant nous nous aurons
l'occasion de faire une fois que la
campagne sera officiellement ouverte
des conférences des prises de paroles
mais sans public veut dire chacun va
être chez soi comme ça se fait un peu
depuis un certain temps mais de manière
plus systématique c'est ce que nous
allons faire
et nous allons évidemment nous adapter
aux circonstances
nous aurions souhaité avoir plus d
échanges avec la population plus de
contact surtout que je suis j'aime le
contact physique j'aime rencontrer les
gens j'aime les toucher j'aime les les
embrasser et ses bons sera pas possible
mais assez yan monplaisir de vous être
prêtés à cet entretien réalisé
aujourd'hui par jean-louis bongo merci
beaucoup et et puis j'espère que tout le
monde ira voter le 28